えーこんにちはえ
吉村と言います
私はこの大学を37年前に
卒業したんですね
こういう男女に立てるとは夢にも思ってませんでした
今日の私のテーマはこれです
早すぎてしまったプロジェクト速過ぎてしまったプロジェクトをやってしまっている
リーダーにアドバイスがあります
そのために私はこれから私の経験をお話しすることなんですけれども
私もですね
今ソニーという会社におりまして
新しい音を起こすプロジェクトを何回がやってきたんですね
しかし失敗することも多くてですねそのお話をすることになることなんです
一つ
ちょっとテレビについてですねちょっとお話したとか歴史ですね
1960年にカラーテレビが登場しました
テレビに色がついたんですねこの時の画素数というのはだいたい40万画素ぐらい
でしょうか
そしてハイビジョンが出たわけですね1999年デジタルハイビジョンですね
画素するにして200万がそうです
ものすごく綺麗になったっていう印象がどなたもあったんじゃないかなと思います
そしてですねー
最近ご存知ですから4型テレビのかねまぁ最近テレビ広告してますわ
これが約800万画素なんですね
で相当
綺麗ではまぁ見た方いらっしゃるかも知れば私も欲しいんですけれども
800万画素ですよそしてこれで終わると思いきやですね
2020年
え
東京オリンピックくるじゃないですか
そうするとですねー
8型というのが出てくるんですよ
と言われていますその画素数が3000万画素以上なんですね
ということで2次元のテレビですが解像度はどんどん上がっていく
4倍4倍4倍ですよ
だけど a
感動ですねそういうふうにヨン倍音バイ
数字のようにあわっていくんでしょうか臨場感が上がっていくんでしょうか
そういうのを疑問にもったんですね僕らは
それは1997年まだ21世紀にもなってない
97年にこういうスケッチを感じました
まあコンセプトスケッチですね
ええまあここに
格闘技スポーツ中継だと思ってください
しかし普通のスポーツ中継ではありません
リングの周りにたくさんカメラがついているんですよ
一つのカメラは映像を撮っていますしかしその何十個というカメラを全部集めたらどう
なるか
それはリング上で行なわれている
空間ですねそれを全部収録してしまうことな軍艦を収録することになる
そしてそれを
まあ将来はネットワークがものすごく速くなってくる
スピードが速くなってきますね
空間事を送ってしまうと
映像を包んではない風化を分
そうするとお客様はどうやって
スポーツ中継を見ることになるでしょうか
例えばですね
follow グラフィンですよこれまだできてないんですけどね
テーブルの上にですね
サッカー場博徒声出てくるんですよ
待ち受け選書おいてんですよね
これでええ右から左から上から見
顔を突っ込むこともね
俺はもうテレビじゃないですね
または例えばこういうもんかもしれません
最近時々音を見かけることがあるかもしれません
大目のところにかけるディスプレイですねえっとマウントディスプレイというんです
けれども
でもそれも
映像見てるにしかすぎません
a
まあこのイラストのようにですねオフィスに見ながら
ここをかけてどう考えても自分はハワイにいるんじゃないか
そこまでの臨場感
できるんじゃないかとデジタルパワーで思ったわけですよ
例えば今私はここに立ってますよ現実の世界です
これはまさに映像ではやりません
私はここに立って右を見ることもできる左を見ることもできること歩いてるんで
そして正面にあなたを見ることができますね
そこにいたらみえな映像です
つまり空間にいるからこそそういうことができるわけですね
それを重慶でできないかと思ったわけなんですね
これができるということはひょっとしてサッカーを見ることもオフに変わるかもしれ
ない
フリーキックの時にね
自分も並ぶんです
ボールを飛んできますわ
はぁっ
ことなのかものすごい感動しますねテレビではできません
つまり水平解像度2次元改造道ですね
どんどん改造して言っても改良していってもこういう体験はできない
ことやらなきゃダメだ
思ったんですよ
8ですねー
ある役員がいいましたわー
同じ女
面白いけどね何十年もかかるよ
言われました
何十年も彼から15年ぐらいはかかるかもしれない
でもそれを言ってしまっちゃダメなんですね
もし15年経たないと成果が出ない言ってしまったらですね
俺は困るわけですよプロジェクトとして成り立たないわけです
どんな長期プロジェクトでも毎年毎年
1回か2回ぐらいは
目立ちビリー
良く言ったんですけども
目立ちビリティーの高い
報告ができないとですね
プロジェクトを続けることはできない
をもう少しやらしてみようかともなるわけです
これをまあ覚えておいて頂きたいと思うんですけども
そこで手を出したのがこれです
360度カメラな
はっはっは
カメラがたくさんついてますよね全部の方向を撮影することで歩き回ることはできない
けど
一箇所ですけれども右左上下
見えるわけですよ
これは単純に綺麗な映像を届けるという発想とは違いますね
こっからいこうと思ったわけです
8ですねその時の初期の映像
学校に機能再生してみたらうまくいったんで再生したいと思う私はヘッドマウント
ディスプレイをつけていますね
移動させないですね右を見れば右アニ
左を見れば左が見えないですね
ちょっと上を見てみましょうかハ見えますね
ネイルんですようん
べしと思いますこれは私の車ですパソコンわっ尻をたくさん積んでまして
ちょっと後ろをみてみましょうか
むしろ後続車が付いてますね動画ですよ
静止画じゃありません u
ストリートビューと違うんですようん
えっと問題はですねー
そういう映像はできたんですけれどもどうやってお客さんに体験してもらうかです
ラッキーなことに99年
ゲーム機派手なんですよ
かなりの性能のんそしてこのゲーム機は dvd というリスク
コンパクトデスク音楽のデスクと違いましたね
同じ12センチですけど容量がかなり入りません
そしてもちろん麺はシーンですからコンピューターの処理は高いものがありますね
ひょっとして僕らの映像がうまく再生できるかもしれないと思っております
そして a とにかく年に変えの目立ちびりてぃですから
実績を出していかなきゃいけません
いくら研究所といっても
それで最初にボーニング娘さんをやったわけだ
そして浜
浜崎あゆみさん
そして浜田省吾さんですね
トップアーティストですよそのコンサートたくさんのカメラ360度でとりまして
そしてを自分はここみたい
もリング娘さんだったら
5巻を見たいとおまけだけを見たいということができるわけです
そういうことができるソフトだったんですね
その後京浜急行の移動させ
剥がしてい
だんだんですね売上苦しくなってきたんですね
若中受けないんですね
というのもええ
まあゲームソフトなんですね正がその中に映像が入ってる映像のソフトだっていうのは
なかなか分かってくださらなかったと思います
湿地られてませんからねこれこういうソフトが出たっていう
そしてついに苦しくなりまして
2,000円3年だったと思いますけれども
水着アイドルをやってしまいました
水着アイドルを好きな角度から見れる
あ誰もが考えそうな事ですよ
それやったんです
ディスクは厳しいなどうしても本来配信をやりたいんです配信を
そこで2つありました演劇とミュージカルです
a これもオリジナルの演劇をやったんですよ
ミュージカルも作りました
ミュージカルの14曲は全部オリジナルです
そしてそれを配信したんですね
演劇ミュージカルは空間芸術であります
生身の役者さんが演技をしてその場で
そして生身のお客さんがその場に行ってそして
まあ楽しむものですね
まあまさに私たちは空間を収録するっていうのがテーマですから
最適の
対象だなと思ってやりました
まぁしかしですね
やっとハチメが見たい寄せメットは
が遅かったんですよ
でももうディスカーもできないと思いましたから
成果としてはあ
堂々と言えるものにはならなかったんです
そして2004年
解散を示した
じゃなかったですねもう心血を注いで絶対正しい
頭も思ってましたから
8まあ新規の授業の解散の藝大ワーク3つぐらいじゃないですかね
ポンセプトに問題
コンセプトそのものに問題があったん
それから時期が早すぎだ
そして
やり方それがまずかったっ
この3つじゃないでしょうかね
特にえーい
早すぎたっていうのはね
多いと思うんです
これはのどんなプロジェクトでもそうだと思うんですけど
ん例えば私たちが360度系から入ったけどちょっとこれはビジネス的に難しいな
思っても今 google さんがストリートビューやってますよね
街中を360度見えるようにして遠いサービスもやってるじゃないですか
そして最近は300度50部のカメラも売っているというのはご存知ですか
ご覧マゾンっと書いてありますんです
でスマホでも観れるんですよ
配信もできます
ということで要するに時代が変わればですね
条件も変わるです
あれだけお金がかかったことあれだけ時間がかかったこと
新武難しかったことも
技術と a 8まあ
世の中は変わりますとグーッと
ハードルが下がります
そうすると一挙にできるタイミングがくるんですね
いろんなプロジェクトをやっている方もいらっしゃる
これからやる方もいらっしゃるしそれから今やってる
いう方もいらっしゃると思いますうん
で
まあ
早すぎてダメになることもあるんですよ
で経験をその時に温存しなきゃいけないと思います
まあ実は私たちのチームも実はその後もええ
結束が固いというっていうかですね
まあそれが忘れなくて技術を蓄えで
そして忘れずにまあこそこそ
裏でやってましたん
とにかく忘れないことですまあ
記憶それから技術を温存しておくことですね
瑛太と一つもう一つプロジェクトリーダーの方にへ
アドがいそうしたいと思います
もし私が2004年ですね
解散したときに
こういう気の利いたこと言えたらもう少し
開発が早くスタートできたんじゃないかなと思うんですね
パソコンの性動画
今から20倍ほど速くなっ
そしてネットワークが
10倍速くなったらそしていつでもどこでもネットワークに繋げられる時代があったら
もう一度集まろうぜん
蓮風にっ
言えたらですね
早くまた再会できたんじゃないかな
というふうに思います
これから新しいことをやる方へ
事情があってひょっとして解散することがあるかもしれません
しかし
世の中が変わると式がガーッと下がっていますそれを忘れないことです
どうもご静聴ありがとうございました